salut je m'appelle fabien olicard dans
ce format nous faisons un focus sur un
point précis du cerveau dans les
épisodes précédents vous avez proposé de
poursuivre matière et cet été avec des
sujets plus fun plus léger ça sera le
cas en juillet et en août
bienvenue dans matière grise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
dans cet épisode nous allons vivre
quatre expériences expérience une avoir
l'oeil le plus rapide expérience 2
devenez le magicien de la soirée
expérience 3 c'est à vous expérience 4
dominé le père fouras le tout avec la
présence très appréciée de rom analystes
vous avez compris qu'aujourd'hui vous
êtes dans un matière grise un petit peu
plus fun en quatre expériences vous
allez débloquer pas moins de six
compétences pour votre cerveau certaines
vont vous êtes très utiles et d'autres
pas du tout juste vous permettra de
faire rire ou d'impressionner tout votre
petit monde cet été avant de passer aux
petits trucs sympas et fun qu'est ce que
vous diriez de lire deux fois plus vite
en ressent beaucoup plus que ce que vous
lisez habituellement ces pratiques pour
dévorer plein de bouquins sur la plage
ou dans les transports en commun je ne
sais pas où vous êtes actuellement il ya
une technique pour ça ça s'appelle la
lecture rapide aujourd'hui
comme je l'aurais déjà expliqué on va
faire on va pas rentrer dans de la
science pour de la science c'est l'été
c'est surtout parce que je suis pas la
bonne personne
tu me tues m'a dit je décroche parfois
de tes explications parce que c'est pas
ma came j'ai après avoir reçu une alarme
gd je comprends robin mais le but c'est
de faire l'utile aujourd'hui je me suis
pour romain l'ours des trucs qui servent
du coloriage kcal 100 g voir les romains
et bien alors on va faire une super
forme génial non je me suis dit la
première chose qui pourrait être
intéressé toi c'est ce qu'on appelle la
lecture rapide
le fait de lire plus rapidement donc il
ya des vraies compétitions de ça des
gens qui font de la lecture rapide qui
lisent 3 4 fois 5 fois plus vite que
nous et qui ont un taux de compréhension
meilleurs que nous c'est un peu fou et
je me suis aperçu que c'était très
pratique mais qu'en même temps la
lecture rapide et un peu des bonnes kg
et aussi sur le côté dans le sens tout
ce qui est dit et pas forcément vrai sur
le sujet et je me suis oui mais nous est
ce qu'on veut devenir des champions de
lecture rapide
aujourd'hui on teste la vitesse de
lecture d'abord donc sans donner de
conseils tu sais que ça ça me fait peur
tu sais pourquoi parce que moi je ne
vois juste que ça c'est à dire que je
m'intéresse pas ce qui est dans un mois
je vois ça et j'avais fait un aller à sa
table de chevet alors qu'en vrai si je
t'avais prix de format poche il est
beaucoup moins épais bouquin saisit
alors qu'ils attendent bande dessinée
c'est encore mieux pour moi avec bella
il n'y a pas autant
moi je te propose le pet à la page 7
tu vas lire autant que tu peux pendant
une minute et après j'ai posé des
questions hu
ok mais un vrai y'a pas de pression
c'est juste que ça fait dix ans qu'on va
pas vous poser une phrase que j'ai mieux
vous allez lire et ensuite je vous pose
avec ce que j'ai toujours rêvé d'être
instituteur à temps elle commence pas à
vitry cité aura un temps défini non en
vrai c'est juste pour voir nocta pas à
lire vite ou quoi tu lis normal combien
de mots tus l'iran combien de temps et
quel est ton taux de compréhension et
après je te donne des conseils
on refait une session et on voit la
différence c'est juste le truc turin
c'est un peu comme du chrono de karting
bah ouais si peut que gagner
allez je me mets dans ces parties
pendant deux minutes
c'est donc 120 secondes donc 30 il va
être surpris j'aurais lu vraiment ça qui
est le pire c'est quand on parle à côté
nungesser et perd peu resté sur le banc
pendant 15 minutes
j'anime pas la vidéo on mettrait en
accéléré s'il faut il n'y a pas de pas
de pression mais soit bon 3 2 1
[Musique]
j'aimerais tourner les pales vie
sportive des patronymes c'est
insupportable
top ten et à quelle page page 8 est un
héros dans la page 8
la première phrase ok donc tu as lu une
page ok n'ouvre pas j'étais quand même
poser des questions quel était le
personnage principal monsieur et madame
dursley exact
est-ce que tu connais le métier de
monsieur dursley dans l'ain souvenirs
qui donne un grand coup ou deux grands
coups j'ai pas trop compris il ya un
fils dans l'histoire ok il y avait un
fils exact alors on disait son métier il
dirige une entreprise qui fabrique des
perceuses est ce que tu peux décrire mad
madame dursley je ne sais pas si c'était
madame ou monsieur mais je crois qu'il
est et où elle était très grande
oui avec comme un double coup oui ok y
avait une histoire comme ça exactement
ok donc on va dire tu as un taux de
compression qui doit être à 5%
je mets le chiffre à peu près au pif
mais en gros qui doit être à 70 %
ça correspond à ces gentils la situation
et les personnages c'est ok par contre
le détail de tout ça quand c'est pas
pertinent pour suivre l'histoire ça
saute assez vite quoi tu vois ok on va
voir si tu peux faire mieux avec les
bases de la lecture rapide et encore une
fois le but c'est pas de lire vite pour
lire vite c'est pas de se dépêcher c'est
juste de perdre moins de temps dans sa
lecture hockey et d'avoir ainsi possible
une très bonne compréhension
le premier conseil c'est un truc qui n'a
rien à voir avec ce qu'on apprend à
l'école c'est quand lee on met son doigt
pour lire d'accord ça paraît stupide
comme ça et aussi le fait de lire à
haute voix
alors quand je veux retenir une
information la plus concrète giro
ben en fait pour deux choses parce que
ça favorise la concentration et ça fait
ce qu'on appelle une boucle phonologique
tiers le tu le dis toi même et tu leur
as en tant que toi même et ça favorise
en fait les circuits mémorielle voilà
pour la petite information je te la
péter lors d'un dîner tu dis beaucoup
plus fort et logique le fait de mettre
son doigt
en fait c'est ça tu fais un guide qui
déjà t'impose un rythme oui tu vois pas
ce que tu vas suivre en fait mon doigt
et en plus de ça sa guide tes yeux et
pourquoi en fait on y perd vite parce
que nos yeux il revient en arrière en
permanence donc ça c'est un très bon
truc à faire tu peux
les voix haute mais en vrai t'es même
pas obligé de lire tous les maux en gros
je vais te demander de passe et on
regarde sur la première ligne sans la
lire je vais mettre mon doigt et tu vas
passer tes yeux aussi vite que mon doigt
sans chercher à lire et tu verras que
malgré tout ta vision périphérique elle
lit et que ton cerveau et lee il n'a pas
besoin ton cerveau que tu lui dises
lille et meaux un par un pour les lire
en fait tu vois il les voit du coin de
l'oeil tu es prêt ouais ok tu as dit
quoi il vit une expression mais les îles
li wei lee d'une expression emmène et
vous mêlez cessa de mépris mais les tu
vois pas ce que je suis allé très vite
mais tu vois en vrai tu as retenu donc
90% de la ligne ok et tu le portes en
tulle lapalu t'as pas lu mot-à-mot dans
ta tête et caetera et tout était yeux
sont jamais revenus en arrière donc ça
c'est juste pour te prouver que c'est
possible en fait tu vois c'est aussi
bête que ça donc là on va refaire alors
peut-être pas deux minutes voire une
minute c'est un peu moins long de
lecture on va faire le chapitre suivant
j'ai donné la page c'est page 26 et je
vais juste demandé de pendant une minute
de lire mais avec le doigt et d'essayer
d'imposer comme ça un rythme tu es prêt
bah je vais me suivez 26 soit on est bon
[Musique]
top monsieur ça fait une minute donc une
minute à lui à peu près ça tu as lu les
trois quarts d'une page en deux fois
moins de temps en 60 secondes c'est pas
mal c'est à dire en deux fois moins de
temps maintenant j'attends les questions
salue ce stand 65 68 pages à la tension
en fait on va faire un verdit mois de
quoi ça parle ou ce que tu as retenu ou
les mots clés que tu as retenu pour
boire alors il ya quelque chose qui
s'est passée en dix ans ouais il a
travaillé 10 ans ou peut-être que ça a
mis dix ans à faire quelque chose
l'histoire d'une fête foraine avec un
ordinateur exact tout le début je n'ai
pas du tout j'ai aucune idée ce qui
s'est passé au début
en fait tu viens de résumer le début
mais de la même manière que tout à
l'heure c'est à dire tu a supprimé des
détails inutiles
en gros il s'est passé un truc en disant
ça a changé etc
mais les petits détails du style le
soleil se leva sur les petits jardins
propres et oui dans sa sujet galles sam
on sert donc en fait c'est là c'est la
même pour l'instant tu as la même
compréhension
sachant qu'en plus c'est une logique ce
que je te fais faire c'est à dire ils
disent ils c'est passé près de dix ans
mais il parle de la page d'avant que
t'as pas lu donc c'est normal que tu es
côté pas le lien j'avais l'impression
d'être intelligent comme ça là aussi
fabuleux forêt l'asie continue fabien
oui c'est ça oui les photos montraient
un gros garçon blond sur son premier
vélo sur un manège de fête foraine
devant un ordinateur en compagnie de son
père
encore une fois là tu gardes les
situations de la même manière pour moi
le seul truc qui m'intéresse c'est que
ça prouve que tu as à peu près la même
compréhension
encore une fois on fait un test avec eux
avec nos gros doigts potelés là c'est à
dire que c'est un test à la louche mais
je vois pas trop de différence de
compréhension alors que juste avec le
doigt talus peut-être trois quart de
page en 60 secondes talus 25 % plus vite
pour la même compréhension et je trouve
que la lecture rapide c'est assez
intéressant là on parle de l'histoire de
fiction mais si tu veux apprendre
détruit que même un truc rôle ou à lire
une notice ou un truc comme ça mais ça
je sais faire tu as tu vois où un
article high tech enfin exemple c'est up
ok you're the one truc parce que ce
geste là oui parce que je connais
tellement bien le sujet déjà que je
trouve là depuis des années que je sais
aller repérer les différences et pour
que instantanément dans ma tête ce soit
ok il ya ça qui changeait tout puis
après c'est un exercice que j'ai fait en
étant invité
et à plein d'événements la semaine sur
plein de produits différents et un
moment où si tu te tapes chaque truc de
presse arrive pas à quoi tu as donc il
faut qu'à un moment tu aille vite et que
tu comprennes les différences entre les
produits pour le recracher correctement
manière compréhensible c'est marrant
parce que c'est vraiment les bases de la
lecture rapide de d'aller plutôt lire on
va dire le geste c'est le regard comme
ça ouais tu vois en zigzag plutôt que de
l'iran mli malling tu vois on le fait
aussi un vecteur epide et pourquoi du
coup toi dans ta compréhension c'est
plus compliqué bien tu viens juste de
donner la clé parce que tu t'es
spécialisé en fait et si demain tu fais
tu te mets à bouffer des romans des
romans des romans des romans en fait tu
vas tu apercevoir que même moi quand je
relis beaucoup de romans les détails
estime je les ai pas beaucoup plus que
toi je vire moi même le superflu dans ma
tête pour aller un petit peu à
l'essentiel tu vois on peut aussi avoir
envie de lire mot-à-mot pour se faire
plaisir dans le style de l'auteur s'est
pas c'est pas pour être toujours dans la
performance
donc ça c'est hyper intéressant écoute
le seul conseil à retenir du coup ces
mets ton doigt quand même quand tu lis
mais comme c'est des kindle permet un
crayon démerde-toi je sais pas on fait
quelque chose être une règle comme avec
auch mais le mail
au final la lecture rapide c'est plein
de choses à retenir c'est juste
favoriser le doigt si on comprend pas
tout c'est pas grave
et c'est pas se mettre de la pression
sur la lecture c'est à dire qu'on lit
pour aller chercher quelque chose dans
son texte il y a que vous qui savez sndi
bien ni mal il n'ya pas un truc
d'élitiste de des gens qui lisent mieux
que d'autres tu vois comment tu lis et
comment tu lis le mieux pour toi je me
suis jetée c'est peut-être bien de faire
passer ce message magazine people à la
plage ça vite aller chercher ce cas cela
donnerait envie je vais à l'expérience
de vous venez donc découvrir la lecture
rapide alors le but c'est pas de perdre
le plaisir de lire et encore moins de ne
pas comprendre retenir ce que vous lisez
d'ailleurs les champions du monde où les
athlètes de la lecture rapide ont bien
souvent un meilleur taux de
compréhension que nous et la raison est
simple lorsqu'on lit nous ne sommes pas
assez concentré nos yeux se fixent à
chaque mot revienne un peu en avant en
arrière on perd le fil voici donc des
techniques simples pour lire plus vite
d'abord suivez le texte avec votre doigt
pour éviter de revenir en arrière et
pour vous imposer un rythme ensuite
essayé de commencer au troisième mot est
de terminer à l'avant dernier mot
en fait c'est votre vision périphérique
qui va prendre le relais sur ce que vous
croyez ne pas avoir lu et enfin essayer
de poser votre regard qu à deux endroits
par ligne vous allez voir que très
rapidement vous aller photographier la
ligne et la comprendre plutôt que de
lire mot-à-mot et si parfois vous avez
envie de lire normalement sans
concentration ultime bain c'est très
bien aussi un vraiment ne perdez pas
votre plaisir
et aujourd'hui je vous préviens
exceptionnellement cet épisode est
sponsorisé par moi même il n'ya plus de
surprise que colloque
j'essaye de bronzer mais j'arrive pas
manipuler le soleil en fait comme la
ceni
comment tu fais la fois un produit là
c'est un indice combien ça mais il faut
un indice 130 cugnaux - mais non mais ça
va moi j'en ai un fera ça protège ta
peau ces lentilles de la manipulation
c'est un soft touch regarde oui bah là
où ça fait quoi mais ça te protège en
fait de toutes les manipulations
cette protégée là je fais bien voir
parce que sinon ils voient pas le titre
du livre et surtout ça fait réflecteurs
sait comment ça ça fait réfléchir
c'est à dire de tulle mais comme ça tu
vas y tient comme ça et donc là le
soleil tape ici et retables ici là comme
ça directement et là tu sens lundi 130
eu le sens mon avis sans tranquille tu
as bien à cela et tu le tiens bien comme
ça parce que sans les gens ils le
verront pas bon après le lien est dans
la description quoi là c'est bien comme
ça exact à melun dit cela je vais bien
m'amuser
merci fabien olicard
[Musique]
l'été c'est sûrement la période où l'on
joue le plus haut car tu es entre-deux
partie basse est toujours l'occasion de
faire un petit tour de magie est là
raconte un peu mais le problème de ces
tours entre amis c'est votre entourage
il n'est pas très concentré alors il
faut que tour il soit rapide efficace et
j'ai ce qu'il vous faut un bon tour
bluffant il ne fonctionnera par contre
que si vous vous entraînez avant et que
vous gardez ensuite le secret sans le
dévoiler à vos spectateurs la magie elle
peut se transmettre c'est exactement ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui mais elle
n'existe que lorsqu'elle est bien traité
voilà c'était mon petit message et si
vous voulez aller plus loin je vous
recommande les livres que vous pouvez
trouver ensuite dans toutes les
boutiques de match on va faire de la
magie et tu m'as dit que tu faisais de
la magie j'ai fait quand j'étais gosse a
dit sans angle j'avais animé un
anniversaire c'est comme ça que je
m'étais fait mon premier petit billet de
50 balles jean mauriac sera pas l'argent
perd toujours c'est un score c'est
exactement ça c'est un score écoute je
te fais voir un tour je te la proie
après pourquoi un petit tour de cartes
parce que je me dis quand tu es en
vacances qui fait souvent les des
parties de cartes et tout ouais mais
c'est un peu style est situé entre deux
partis du fait qu'elle fait un petit
tour de magie et tout donc je te fais le
tour et après je t'aide apprend et du
coup je vous l'apprends même temps un
tour dont vous devez prendre soin ne pas
répéter un tour avant de le faire c'est
juste la science de la foire et donc
nous on va y arriver très vite parce que
c'est un professionnel
non je mélange les cartes parce que ça
me fait plaisir mais c'est pas du tout
obligatoire et on pourrait dire que si
je prenais les cartes dans mes mains
comme ça je pourrais manipuler autant
que je veux donc on va faire un truc
très simple donc et pas de carte bleue
ou à l'envers autre chose comme ça dans
le paquet
je vais surtout les sécuriser à l'aide
d'un élastique alors peu importe la
taille s'il est trop grand on fait deux
tours de klein maintenant qu' à
l'élastique en sais que je peux pas
retirer des cartes comme je veux ok
d'accord mais je me suis dit un tour de
cartes pendant l'été on sait qu'ils vont
pas à voir la tension fut que le to rail
très vite donc je me suis dis juste un
tour comme ça où tu prends le jeu qui a
entouré d'un élastique tu le tape deux
trois points comme ça
et tu fais sortir les 4 as alors c'est
de claquer toujours dans l'est ça c'est
très très énervant c'est pas si mal ça
ouais ok dans douze secondes tu sais
faire
on y va this party hockey ton paquet mon
paquet premier truc qui sort les 4 as et
tuent les isole du reste du paquet les
quatre as tu l'aimés sur las on appelle
ça la face du paquet c'est à dire le
côté face visible d'accord tu retournes
l'ensemble je retourne l'ensemble hélas
le tour est prêt ouais on n'est pas sur
une grosse prépare en gros ou mettez les
quatre à sandra deuxième étape on
prépare un élastique un petit ou un gros
je te conseille un petit donc on est
d'accord tout à l'heure tu as fait des
faux mélangent exact il faut absolument
que vous fassiez un espace entre les 4 à
5 reste du paquet le plus simple pour ça
c'est dire bon ben tu vois il n'y a pas
de carte retournée elles sont toutes
normale et lacan visuellement vous voyez
qu'il ya split quatre cartes vous
séparer un peu et vous mettez un doigt
comme ça titre l'annulaire entre le
paquet et les cartes de dos et timide on
voit les germes ou le truc de face on
voit rien en fait donc vous avez votre
paquet quelqu'un c'est avec votre gros
doigts derrière comme importe chaud vous
prenez votre élastique et là vous allez
faire semblant d'enrouler le paquet sauf
qu'en fait vous le passez par l'arrière
et vous ne mettez pas surtout pas en
fait avec les as vous entoure et que le
paquet alors moi là j'ai un jardin gros
élastique
si ça vous arrive vous faites un
deuxième tour est pareil ce deuxième
tour vous allez encore le passé sans
prendre les airs c'est ensuite vous
pouvez enlever votre gros doigts qui ne
sert plus à rien et donc là vous êtes
dans une situation où pour les pour les
spectateurs votre élastique entoure tout
le paquet mais en fait dans la réalité
vous avez bien un paquet avec un
élastique et quatre cartes qui sont
complètement libres donc là le plus
simple maintenant à faire j'ai pris on
va dire la partie supérieure du paquet
comme ça mais la partie inférieure de la
tenue j'ai commencé à essayer de le
tirer mais
on pourrai je pense faire plus simple
c'est à dire faire comme ça tu as ton
paquet en un gauche vous faites pareil
ta main droite vient prendre la partie
moitié supérieure du paquet il omet
perpendiculaire en forçant sur
l'élastique l'impression qu'il se passe
quelque chose et après je fais semblant
de taper et à trois je vais juste tout
lâcher sur la table mais je vais lâcher
de manière à ce que le papier ils se
remettent en place et sa teneur ça va
tomber à côté tu as dit simple c'est sa
taille et ses chercher un tour c'est moi
c'est non mais juste pour conçu dit pas
dans les commentaires si c'est simple à
la plage
donc là je tire comme ça et on regarde
je lâche tout à la limite tu vois c'est
un peu moins stylé de que quand je
quitte eu l'effet de chaleur mais sa
phase qui s'écrit toi mais si je me dis
ça oui ça oui ok maintenant il faut que
tu me le fasse dans la continuité et un
peu style et qui est prêt à me faire ça
ok je suis fabien je viens de la plage
et je te dire marie - tours
salut fabien hérard c'est pas toi qui
fais des tours de magie
aujourd'hui il va acquérir
c'est gênant ouais tu vois j'ai un
paquet normal c'est vrai pas remarqué au
caire à qui es tu veux que je mélange
quand même par sécu ainsi tu je le
rajoute la griffe excepté quelques jeux
c'est chouette hockey à obstacles se
mélangent voilà ça s'est bien arrangé
mais ça veut garder tel qu'on s'est
arrêté à ce n'est pas mal quand même
entre pas vu j'étais patient en vrai on
peut souligner le bon travail d'escrocs
alors après c'est la partie technique où
donc tu as passé un bon moment
tabiou ricard avec tes copains ok je
n'ai pas du tout après une technique
pour justifier ton geste
si vous avez du mal à faire comme romain
ce truc là vous dites il n'est pas
arrivé jean jacques
non bon alors je te disais ok
bon là tu vas voir il va se passer un
truc formidable
samassa marché très bien de face devrait
se passer un truc formidable je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai envie de faire ça mais je
vais le faire regarder je trouve sur le
toit qui était prêt mais bon il ya
participé grave mais j'ai des 4 as je
retiens deux choses que en moins d'une
minute hambourg et tu sais le refaire et
que sans entraînement c'est un peu
dégueulasse donc entraîner vous un petit
peu et en vrai vous leur offrez sais pas
si nous envoie denrées s'écoule pas vrai
ça se fait tu passes un quart d'heure un
peu de confiance en soi devant le miroir
pour se rassurer et puis j'avais quoi tu
vois parce que là c'est juste parce que
ton élastique il était tôt réduit de
mètres plus au centre
mais c'est pas mal bravo romain merci
fabien alors entraînez vous bien pour le
faire entre deux parties de cartes c'est
vraiment bluffant est assez cool
d'ailleurs vous pouvez faire remarquer
que les jeux de cartes ont beaucoup de
points communs avec le calendrier
je vous explique il ya deux couleurs le
rouge et le noir un petit peu comme les
deux périodes de l'année où il ya une
période qui est plus chaud des périodes
les plus froides
il ya quatre familles piqueur carreaux
trêve comme les quatre saisons printemps
été automne hiver il ya 52 cartes dans
un paquet comme les 52 semaines d'une
année et si on fait la somme de tous les
points d'un paquet alors on dit que le
valais vaud 11 la dame vaut 12 leroy
votre aise
ça fait 3 164 points et avec le premier
joker 365 le nombre de jours dans une
année
le deuxième jeu joker pour les années
bissextiles il ya énormément de points
communs comme ça entre les jeux de
cartes et les calendriers
dans ce set avoue spécialités et des
blocages de cerveau il n'y aura pas de
test sur du savoir mais bien trois
expériences très courte qui vont vous
servir ou pas juste vous amusez vous
êtes prêts alors c'est parti je sais pas
du tout ce bruit expérience 3 c'est à
vous c'est des trucs que vous pouvez
refaire chez vous un terme à ce sont des
questions de sciences et tout
aujourd'hui c'est du pratique là c'est
un truc que tu peux faire la fin des
repas j'adore ces trucs là il ya de
l'eau c'est que de l'eau dans l'assiette
à copier durant le repas à l'apéro ou
quand tu attends que ça sert et où tu
mets du sel comme ça à mort après tu
mets du poivre à temps mais il n'a pas
été ouverte que ça ah oui nous rappelle
que j'aurais tellement voulu qu'ils
continuent deux minutes après tu mets du
poivre alors pas trop
ah oui c'est un truc peut-être pas ces
moyens non exactement alors on est
d'accord que si je trempe mon doigt
rien ne se passe parce que je sais pas
magnétisés par contre si je me frotte un
peu contre tes poils
c'est incroyable ce qui se passe je te
transmets locaux vides t1 c'est un an et
demi un combat photo c'est comme ça
aussi mi temps normal je suis beaucoup
pouvoir c'est fou et ça écarte de ouf ça
marche trop bien c'est pas trop stylé
que pas apprendre à le faire par contre
faut vraiment du coup donc je récapitule
prendre une assiette
allez la remplir d'eau peut-être que tu
ne connais pas cette personne dont la
frotter cette personne ouais ça c'est
alors frotté ça servait à rien ah merde
alors je suis vraiment d'accord génial
c'est une réussite fin de tournage
alors il ya un élément que t'as pas je
vais je vais demander à jérémy demeue la
porte et se plaît donc il faut vraiment
du sel ça c'est pas une blague
il faut vraiment de l'eau du poivre et
de la drogue
ça c'est pas une blague il faut de la
méta ça c'est une blague spot de meta
c'est du liquide vaisselle n'importe
lequel on s'en fiche en fait il nous
faut du savon ces cinq hommes qui va
libérer la tension qui au dessus de
l'eau tu t'en mets un petit peu sur le
doigt est donc le premier coup si tu
l'as sur l'index tu trempe ton doigt que
tu n'as pas mis au préalable
tu n'as pas en voilà et il se passera
rien d'accord et ensuite tu fais ce que
tu veux tu dis une formule magique où tu
te concentres ce que tu veux et là tu
mets le doigt qui contient le produit
est là ça va libérer la tension qui
antibes l'eau et ça tout viré et c'est
us et d'expliquer pourquoi
oui c'est la tension de surface s'est
passé extrêmement satisfaisant oui mais
j'adore ça
donc ça vous pouvez leur faire un repas
c'est très cool une fois que vous avez
mis le bordel
vous pouvez dire bon j'ai un autre tour
que je dois vous faire avec un briquet
et je sais tout transformer en brique et
bien heureusement par exemple ceci est
imbriqué mais lui il marche pas il a
plus de gaz donc tu peux reprendre sa et
la marche pas il ya plus de gaz par
contre que prendre ça mais ça marche pas
il ya plus de gaz c'est très chiant ça
les analyses sur le bruit du briquet
ouais tu prends un vrai briquet et avec
la roulette qui le fait disparaître
cette année vous allez ça je sais que de
toute cette vidéo c'est le truc que vous
allez retenir et refaire tous tout le
temps c'est rien mais c'est moi aussi ça
me fait délirer c'est tout non mais t'es
sérieux t'a pas briques et twitter t'as
pas un briquet qui sort de ta main
magique et où et avec la paume de la
main ça rend ton bruit un peu plus
métallique
mais ce qui est très drôle avec ce truc
là c'est que tu peux dire attends je
prends mon briquet tu fais semblant
vraiment d'en prendre un fait bon il a
plus de gaz c'est vrai en même temps je
m'étais dit que tu m'avais pas invités
puisque épouse anne et essaye de le
faire quand même faut qu on leur
démontre que tu arrives à le faire donc
tu veux juste allume non ça va pas trop
bien peu trop rapide trop fort tu vois
et le truc en vrai ça est vachement de
le faire avec le pouce parce que ton
pouce il fais pas ça sur un briquet tu y
es tu vas au même rythme dans gow normal
tu ferais aller franchement l'a fait
après donc et basit tu peux prendre ce
que tu veux tous les non fumeurs
franchement c'est pas mal ça chez vous
pas vrai ça fait très magnifique et je
te recommande vraiment de la petite
astuce de faire semblant de prendre un
briquet je ne marche pas mais j'imagine
tellement la blague quelqu'un qui te
demande vraiment rapidement si tu as du
feu chez voilà temps j'arrive le parquet
concernant ce cas là dessus on part pour
la 4 voilà comment on peut faire
fonctionner son cerveau l'été en
travaillant les illusions générés par le
cerveau comme le bric invisible ou alors
en faisant de la science pourquoi le
poivre s'est écartée si vous cherchez
vous allez découvrir le monde
merveilleux de la tension superficielle
et vous est de même pour savoir ensuite
pourquoi les insectes peuvent parfois
marcher sur l'eau donc quatrième
expérience dominé le père fouras alors
attention je vous vois déjà bondir chez
vous on dit pas le père fouras non alors
déjà je le sais parce que je viens de la
rochelle et ses proches de la ville de
fouras qui a donné son nom au père
fouras et je peux vous dire qu'on rigole
bien quand on entend quelqu'un qui
cherche la ville de fouras
mais plus loin que ça si vous regardez
des dizaines d'années d'épisodes de fort
boyard à aucun moment donné ils disent
le père fouras c'est une idée reçue
mais si un jour vous avez vu fort boyard
vous avez aussi sûrement vu le jeu des
bâtonnets des bâtonnets kiala il existe
une technique pour gagner à tous les
coups mais vraiment tous les coups vous
pourriez d'ailleurs prendre autre chose
que des bateaux nerfs si vous voulez le
faire cet été des crayons des cailloux
des bouts de papier peu importe la règle
est simple vous avez le droit de prendre
à deux ou trois bâtons et celui qui
prend le dernier bat on a perdu et c'est
comme ça que j'ai invité roumain pour le
faire perdre à ce jeu là
tu as déjà regardé fort boyard oui tu
regardes encore non d'accord détecteur
de mensonges dans nos produits on va
faire un des jeux très célèbre de fort
boyard c'est le jeu des bâtonnets convoi
dans la salle avec les maîtres du fort
ou je sais pas quoi l'aller ils font des
trucs à la fin pour gagner des secondes
donc chacun lieu d'un côté de la table
et les joueurs jouent l'un après l'autre
et ont le droit de retirer un deux ou
trois bâtons et le dernier qui prend le
dernier bat on a perdu
donc tu dois faire en sorte de ne pas
prendre le dernier bâtons et de forcer
l'autre à le prendre
ok on va faire une partie ans et après
je t'apprends commet toujours gagné donc
a priori je suis censé gagner un chéri
tu commences je commence quand je
commence ok donc un deux ou trois bâtons
et ne prend pas le dernier où tu as
perdu
il fallait
il était tout seul
est ce que tu es en train de constater
que tina fey déchets patois à partir de
ce moment là et le dernier pour toi ça
va me rendre fou je ne sors pas dit
j'adore ce truc bon alors j'ai vraiment
une méthode logique pour gagner ce jeu
il se joue à 24 bâtonnets mais en gros
la méthode pour gagner elle elle
fonctionne à partir du moment où il ya
un multiple de 4 ans bâton qu'il y avait
eu 20 bâton 24 28 32 peu importe si
c'est un multiple de 4 ça fonctionne
sinon on peut adapter la méthode le but
du jeu c'est que au départ six toi tu
commences à jouer je vais faire en sorte
que l après à la fin de mon tour y ait
au moins trois bâtons ou six bâtons de
retirer donc le premier coup toi si tu
commences à jouer donc si l'adversaire
commence je vais faire en sorte de
compléter sa prise pour atteindre les
trois bâtons ou les six bâtons de
retirer d'accord donc toi tout à l'heure
tu avais enlevé de bâton j'en ai enlevé
un pour faire trois sites en avait pris
1 j'en aurais pris deux sites en avait
pris trois jeunes auraient pris 3 aussi
pour faire 6 ok d'accord et ensuite
toutes les prises vont dépendre
détiennent à partir de là je vais
toujours complété pas prises pour faire
4 si tu en prends donc ça t'arrange et
que je démarre non parce que j'ai aussi
linverse si c'est moi qui avait démarré
en aurait pris deux j'en aurais pris 3
directement en fait mon but c'est que
tout de suite enlevé un multiple de 3 tu
vois donc comme tout a commencé j'ai
fait en sorte d'atteindre le 3 si
j'avais commencé j'en aurai retiré trois
moi même donc ça ça revient au même et
après je vais toujours complété pas
prises pour atteindre le chiffre 4 il en
prend 1 j'en prends trois sites en prend
deux j'en prends 2 6 33 j'en prends 1
pourquoi parce que un lot de 4 1 l'autre
4 un autre 4 un autre 4 et on va arriver
exactement à quand tu as compris que tu
avais perdu quand il en reste cinq quand
il reste 5 t'es foutu les foutu parce
que si tu en prends un j'en prends trois
sites en prend deux j'en prends 2 et si
tu en prends trois j'en prends un donc
je te laisserais toujours le tient donc
à chaque fois tu une fois qu'on aura
réglé ce problème de la première prise
de troie à chaque fois que tu complétera
m'a prise pour faire 4 hockey et il
suffit de le faire une fois et vous
allez mieux compte
on nettoie aussi donc je suis
l'adversaire j'ai décidé de commencer
j'en prends de hockey donc là j'en
prends de nantes 3 3 pour être exact roi
aussi sur vos débuts au kg gré de la ce
est parti maintenant sur l'app risque
est donc là j'en prends deux d'accord
hélas si je veux te faire croire que a
maintenant après je peux être emmerdé
donc il faut mais parce que tu as l'air
tu m'as pas vraiment copier non je n'ai
pas copié g couple et été prise pour
faire 4 tu vois d'argentan je me sens
exact à exactement là j'en crois en
trois ok donc l'agent points exactement
là j'en prends lune là j'en prends 3
ouais ça j'en prends 2 et là bas je suis
emmerdé quoi que je fasse j'ai perdu
donc si j'en prends 2 par exemple
eh ben je suis obligé de prendre le
dernier j'ai pas le choix
comment tu fais à battre dans ces
conditions si je connais pareil que toi
la règle tu as bien on essaie allez je
commence donc moi logiquement comme je
connais la règle veut atteindre le 6
c'est exactement ça qui se passe quand
les deux connaissent comme ça tu vas
faire ça moi ça si toi tu veux gagner
faut que tu en prennes qu'un seul à ce
moment là ok et là tu me mets dedans
donc si les deux connaissent la
technique tu as tout intérêt à commencer
parce que si on fait 3 3 3 3 3 après 3
prend 1 et là je reviens à ce [ __ ] de
truc de quoi qu'il arrive j'ai perdu si
j'en prends 3d donc là où tu gagneras
toi c'est quand tu commenceras toi la
partie mais si on part du principe du
mat donc et deux connaissent la
technique et vont le faire il faut que
tu commences pour gagner merci à vous
merci à tous les participants à toute
l'équipe à fannie et jérémie à la
production à loïc à la réalisation avec
toute son équipe est bien sûr à romane
âneries n'hésitez pas à découvrir ces
vidéos le lien est en bas dans la
description vous pouvez partager cette
vidéo vous pouvez lalique et et si cette
série vous plaît vous pouvez vous
abonner gratuitement à cette chaîne
youtube
vous avez également tous les épisodes
précédents de matière grise les neuf
dans la description ainsi qu'une
playlist alors pouvons nous débloquer
des choses encore plus amusantes ou
intéressantes dans notre cerveau sommes
nous capables de faire évoluer nos
méninges même l'été est ce qu'il y aura
une saison 2 de matière grise vous aurez
la réponse à tout cela et bien plus dans
les prochains épisodes de matière grise
à très bientôt ciao